[Music]
our next speaker
is a new friend of mine and i'm happy to
introduce please join me in welcoming
andrew mongano
all right how we doing
we all set hello and welcome
uh to san francisco i'm so excited to be
here
speaking at uh our studio conference um
i'll explain a little bit about
about my background um but uh
this is one of my favorite conferences
um definitely top two in san francisco
uh
um but i'm excited to be here uh excited
to talk to you about
growth hacking with r and different
analytics
so with that if you've ever heard a
salesforce presentation before
you know what's coming next and that's
the forward-looking statement
so i'm not really going to talk about
salesforce software today
however if you are considering buying
salesforce please make sure that you
consider only
features that are regularly available in
the market okay now that's out of the
way
i'm going to give you a little bit of an
introduction for myself a little bit of
a personal background
i studied undergrad at upenn
economics and film studies so left brain
right brain
and when i graduated um i went into
a career that was hiring i graduated in
the recession
and i spent the first 10 years of my
career at macy's
doing merchandising and you know it
it was a great company to learn business
it was in transition there was a data
transition happening
but i didn't quite feel the right
fit professionally and i was looking for
somewhere to go
looking how to transition and it was
very difficult
you know we had a statistics department
but they were all phds
and fortunately the world changed and
right at this point
this little red line i discovered are
and it was this community that's helped
each other
that's educated that's helped me
transform not only my career
but my life my family
it took me to a masters in analytics
from nyu
i relocated from the east coast to the
west coast and worked in e-commerce
grocery
and then most recently now at salesforce
doing
uh software analytics product analytics
and data science
uh and so really the thing that i need
to say more than anything
is thank you thank you to this community
you've helped me
in ways that you can't really know and i
really truly appreciate that
which is why i'm so excited to hear to
talk to you about my topic and hopefully
give back a little bit
so before we get started i'll just talk
real quickly what is salesforce
uh if you're in san francisco and you
ask different people you'll say what is
salesforce
most people say it's a tower some people
will say
it's a transit center but really what is
it uh
salesforce brings customers
and companies together and that's really
what our mission is
and how we do that is through a suite of
cloud software products if you work in
sales you're very familiar with sales
cloud
but service cloud powers um uh
uh customer call centers and customer
service uh marketing cloud touches
almost everybody here
through targeted marketing emails push
notifications
commerce cloud runs e-commerce website
so there's a whole suite
of cloud-based applications
most recently in the analytics cloud for
us is tableau which is a recent
acquisition
underneath that we have a platform of
technologies and emerging technologies
that are built right into salesforce
so mobile blockchain artificial
intelligence with our einstein
so this is what salesforce is it is a
big company with petabytes of data
and who deals with the data and that
would be the data intelligence team
at salesforce and that's the team that i
work on uh our team is divided into five
pillars
of the modern challenges
of data at a company um but what i'll
talk to
for myself most important uh is strategy
and growth
and that leads into into this talk
so the customer journey um particularly
for
uh sas companies deals with acquisition
retention
keeping the customers and then
cross-selling and upselling
and so this customer journey
has a lot of support behind it in steps
one
and three and primarily uh
acquiring new customers is very robust
with marketing attribution analysis
and a lot of marketing analytics that is
very well codified
and the same thing with the last step
with cross-selling market basket
analysis
our pre-order algorithm there's books
about it they teach it in school
and so it's something that's very fairly
common but retention analytics i found
and particularly when we're doing hiring
is a lot
less structured and a lot less
organized in an academic sense and so
what is that middle piece
uh and so what i'm calling it today
growth hacking but also growth analytics
and retention analytics
is focusing on the customers that you
have so not worrying about cross-selling
or
acquisition but focusing on how to keep
users
how to keep customers and we have some
primary metrics
that are very important to growth
analytics and retention analytics
the big one is mao and what's different
from software
from other businesses and you can see
this when you read it in the news
is that they don't talk about sales they
don't talk about clicks or purchases or
items
if you read about slack versus microsoft
teams or things like that
they talk about users and active users
and that's the primary metric that we
focus on really targeting in and zeroing
on that
growth analytics is related to ltv and
ltv analysis
but it differs in some key ways and i'll
show kind of example of that
and really the interesting thing about
this analysis it's fairly simple
but the key is to finding different
segments and cohorts within the data
to find differences between that and
i'll show that how to do that with
with this talk so we're going to focus
today mostly on mal and retention
but there's a lot of challenges with
retention analytics
and the challenge is that we tend to use
log data so we use instrumented data on
logs it could be logs from a website
logs within software but it's machine
logs this is mostly for engineers this
isn't optimized for analytics
but they're abundant there's like i said
petabytes
of data that you can use it's just it's
really hard to use because
it could be redundant there could be
many challenges with it and it requires
a lot of transformation
and there are commercial tools available
however they are
very expensive and this is our studio
this is our conference
we want it to be free and open source
and the challenge that i find and what i
see
is that there's a skills gap in taking
those raw logs
and converting it to an action and an
insight and so what i'm going to show
here is using the tidy verse syntax
generating product analytics kpis with
very little code so if you were looking
for something
using pca in something really complex i
apologize this is going to be
very very concise and hopefully very
usable
retention analytics and r all right so
we're gonna use four main packages today
obviously the tidy verse uh we're gonna
use plotly
formattable which is based off of
knitter and then html widgets
the data that we're going to use is all
generated
uh it is random it is not any user data
from salesforce or anything like that
um but that data set is something that
uh that we will release about how to
generate it so you too can do this
and so when we look at the data what we
see is we see it's at the month grain
we have a user id so we have user logs
per month
and then we have some let's call it
demographic data behind it so maybe what
industry
this user is in what region
and we'll show you how to how to slice
that on cohorts
now what's really interesting when you
think about retention analytics
and the key kpi of mao are
does not have in its base diff time
function
monthly units it stops at weeks uh and
this was really interesting because you
could be kind of working through this
and say
why isn't it working a month what's
wrong with my code why why am i
calculating months
in millisecond intervals and so to get
around that
uh this is actually the our community
that posted this on stack overflow
as a custom function to do monthly
intervals
and so we're going to rely on that with
some other functions
okay we take that raw data set of logs
and using really two lines we mutate it
uh very easily to get the most important
piece of information for retention
analytics
so we're going to group by the user id
and then we're going to mutate and we're
going to add
an age and the first month the start
month and this start month is when we
first see that user
that's time 0. you'll see why that's
important
and because we use mutate we use custom
functions it's very easy we're just
going to use this elapsed month
function okay
this is the retention code this
is what will generate all of our
visualizations all of our analysis
and i apologize if you were looking for
pca
it or hyper planes or multi-dimension it
is very easy it is only three lines
once we have that age data we're going
to group it by that age we're going to
summarize it by looking
at a total users over time and then
we're going to mutate what this
retention percentage is
so this what we see is that we have 13
000 users to start with in their total
data set
13 000 users that initially start and
then over time you see them falling off
this is very good for somebody to just
sort of see in a table but it doesn't
really make sense
and so what we do then is we show it in
a gigi plot
and what this table shows what this
chart shows on the x-axis
is sort of that age that life what is
that life of the user
and how many users do you retain over
time and what's important for software
is that if your
user base goes to zero after a certain
amount of time you probably have some
problems with your product
or you have a certain product that needs
a certain fit you need to keep releasing
new things but
for this if you're in software if you're
in sas business like this
and you go towards xero something's
wrong and you need to see that
and this is the base function that we
look at but
what's more important is the analysis in
finding those different cohorts
and so just by changing that one line by
changing that group by function
and by adding a color all of a sudden
you have something much more useful and
much more insightful
so what are the differences between my
users where are they coming from why
why are the retention why is the
retention different between the two
and you can see it somebody can
understand uh in this case maybe how the
banking industry is outperforming
the tech industry for user retention and
that leads to business insights and then
strategies
now this is useful um but it's also hard
to read you know if you look at it you
can say well at 10 months
what's the overall difference between
the two groups
you can kind of parse it out but not so
great and that's where we use plotly
and again i apologize how simple it is
you take that gg plot that we did in the
last chart that we saved
a gigi chart variable and all you do is
you just put it into ggplotly
and because of the community that's
coded this the work is done and you can
see very easily an end user can see
the differences between the groups in a
visual form and they can really
see and understand what's going on with
their user base
okay now r being the fantastic tool that
it is
can handle much more complexity than
that and so one of the things that we
look at is we can look at change over
time
and the change over time can be
represented by the starting of the
different cohorts and what we see in
this chart
is that we have two years of data
and while it looks like spaghetti based
on the coloring schemes that
r just did right out of the box changing
that date to a factor you're able to see
what's really going on
within your user cohorts and this could
lead to some useful insights for either
seasonality or differences between
customers and user groups
great what we're going to move to
from a visual form and
those retention curves look great on
charts but sometimes you need to go
deeper sometimes you need a little bit
more
insights about granularity about when
something happened when
so this is where we're going to use
the tidy verse to stack different
functions
to make very clean chart outputs and so
what we have here is we have that same
uh retention curve that we just saw in a
visual form
but we're looking at it as a table so
that the start month on the left
january 2018 you know you can follow
that diagonal
where you retain you know all of your
users that's when they start so you have
100
and as you go each subsequent column
each subsequent month
you can see how many of the customers
how many of the users you retain
and so you can see it falls off but it's
hard to read it's hard to follow
so what we're going to do is we're going
to add we're going to use the scales
package uh clean it up a little bit
we're going to replace the nas
and we're going to make it easier to
read so this is an improvement this is
starting to get something that's human
readable
but we can still do better we're going
to add a little bit more information
and using the tidy verse we're going to
stack a join on top of it
to show you the size of the cohort so
now what you see
you're packing more and more information
you're saying which months are important
what is my retention over time and now
you're starting to add some
understanding to it
but it's still a little bit hard to read
there's a lot of numbers um
you know maybe your data scientists
don't like to read as much maybe your
business partners don't
uh so we need to make this a little bit
easier to understand and so what we're
going to do is we're going to use the
formattable package
we're going to add a lot of gobbledygook
code that i'm going to truncate at the
bottom but what we're going to do is
we're going to format it
in something that's much more readable
and so we create a table like this
where you have that retention data that
cohort data that cohort size
and you've color coded so now you see
over time that things are consistent
but you really can see what's going on
with your user base
so that you can see differences and try
to uncover what's really going on
again r can handle a lot of complexity
and the complexity fortunately for us is
very easy to handle
so by adding again just two variables
in very simple places
you can add much more granularity by
looking at the industry
over time and what the retention is and
so compared to the last chart you see
that this group is over
as outperforming in terms of retention
the other group
but it's these slices these splits
within the data that you can look at
to identify differences between users
and differences within your product
this could be users that take a certain
action
and that's where things really start to
get a little bit interesting
okay so we've built this we've built
this tool we built it
again very very simply but it's not just
for us
we need to get it in the hands of
business partners and make it a little
bit easier and you could build it into a
shiny application you could host a shiny
application
but sometimes there's an easier way and
sometimes you might not have the
infrastructure
so with html widgets you just save it as
a widget
and what you get is you get an
interactive chart
that an end user doesn't need to know
anything about r
they don't need to know anything about
what you're doing they just need to know
the language about how to interpret it
and now they can use it so you can
generate this you can generate this
automatically you can host it on a
server and then
you know even without going through
something like using r
and um a shiny package you get a table
so again very very simple code and what
i've
sort of showed was basically what is
retention analytics
this is a way to kind of get you primed
and started about
what this field is about in growth
hacking and retention
but i have a confession to make because
um
it's not entirely true about uh the
field
not really having uh academic work and
and being codified as much
and i'm gonna make a plug for your our
meetup groups
and so i was talking with the bay area
our meetup group and i was talking about
retention
analytics and a few other product
analytics and they said to me
you know actually what you're doing is
just
applied survival analysis and so i was
thinking about it and i looked at it and
i said
wait a second that's interesting i
talked to university professor
about growth hacking and survival
analysis and this was new to them
and that's when i realized that this our
community bringing different groups
together bringing different fields
is really where the cutting edge is and
joining all that thing is where there's
a lot of creativity
uh and so the survival packages and some
survival analysis packages i'm not gonna
go into detail into this
but if you look at that kaplan-meier
curve that
is a retention curve that we look at in
product analytics
and you can see the differences between
it uh what you have is you have a hazard
function
and a regression analysis on the right
so looking at that same data
in a different way and that's really
what engages me so much in the art
community is that you take something
that was over here
you take science that was over there you
bring them closer together
and we're all better off for it so i'm
gonna make a plug then
um if you'd like to learn more about
survival analysis
and start to think about how you might
apply this to your own
growth hacking to your own product
analytics there's a fantastic
detailed book about applied survival
analysis using r
but if you want to get started there's a
gentleman
at the conference i'd like to think he's
a friend of mine and he's helped me
very much joe rickard runs the rvu's
blog which i highly recommend and in
this blog he actually talked about
survival analysis during r
using r uh and is a great primer to take
the simple code that we did and that
data
and use survival analysis and apply to
it so
go to the r meetups meet people interact
with everybody
and new ideas will come out of it and
make all of us
uh better so
if you're interested in salesforce this
is the slide you want to take pictures
of
or you can come talk to me um join the
ohana
join data intelligence at salesforce we
are
a leader in doing well and doing good
and so a lot of the themes that jj
talked about this morning
is really what salesforce stands for we
are a leader in innovation
a leader in philanthropy and most
importantly in culture
trust is our number one value customer
success
innovation and quality it is one of the
best places in the world to work
i absolutely love it and would
definitely recommend you to
again check out the careers and with
that i definitely want to say
thank you thank you for having me uh i
hope this was helpful to you
and i definitely look forward to
answering any questions or connecting
with you
later at the conference thank you very
much
[Applause]
we have time for one or perfect
questions here
i i can read i can hear any questions
here we go all right
um so here we go
so we have the retention stats grouped
by these variables what are some actions
you can take to increase
the retention rate that's a great that's
a great question so
trying to understand this is like the
step one this is understanding what your
users are doing
and then trying to figure out strategies
what you might do
to improve retention so you might
actually do some
discovery about why a certain group is
falling off
and you know if you're talking about
software analysis you might have to
build new features build new products
if you're talking about traditional
business like how i've used this before
you might have to work on your product
market fit
you mentioned that you have petabytes of
log data
where the analytics are applied things
are moving
can you talk about um what teams inside
salesforce
are in charge of processing that data
how do you get
that into analyzable form is that your
team another team
how does that work uh yeah i would say
it's that larger
data intelligence organizations so
petabytes of data is is very challenging
to work with
um but there's so many tools now at
scale between
spark between hive that we that we use
and really r has great connectors to all
of those to
to connect to it so much so that i do
most of this uh by myself with
supportive infrastructure teams
awesome all right let's do one more uh
is there a good way to account for
how many months a user could be retained
so i'm not sure i understand so it has
how long someone could be and that's
really where
those curves kind of come in so if
somebody falls off early but
maybe someone else who looks like them a
lookalike model maybe hasn't uh there's
a lot of randomness that you could see
uh but i would say you know definitely
that's really where the fun is in the
analysis and trying to understand that
awesome all right thank you so much
great thank you so much please come say
hi
uh thank you very much